[Musique]
il portait des bretelles en mon honneur je n'ai jamais
oublié que
je n'ai jamais oublié d'où je venais j'ai quitté
brooklyn ne m'a jamais quitté
c'est l'un des grands honneurs de ma
longue carrière juste d'être
sur la même terre que toi
tu as toujours  vous vous êtes décrit à moi
et à presque tout
le monde comme un enfant de Brooklyn c'est là que je suis
qu'est-ce que cela signifie que
cela signifie que je suis un enfant de Brooklyn qui a
marché dans les rues avec mes amis et
qui a toujours voulu être à l'antenne je
ne  Je ne sais pas pourquoi,
mais j'étais en transe avec la radio
et j'étais ce pauvre petit garçon que nous étions
en relève.
Mon père était mort quand j'avais neuf ans. La
ville de New York a acheté ma première paire de
lunettes.
je viens et c'est vrai
jusqu'à présent
je n'ai jamais oublié d'où je viens donc j'ai
85 ans
mais je suis le gamin de brooklyn ii j'ai quitté
brooklyn
mais brooklyn ne m'a jamais quitté
donc ça fait partie de mon âme et c'est
et c'est quoi  j'ai apporté à l'
entreprise étant curieux d'
être ce gamin  qui est allé à des jeux douteux
tous mes amis voudraient des autographes
je voudrais poser des questions je me souviens
d'avoir couru dans la rue avec carl
ferrillo
vous savez où avez-vous obtenu ce bras comment
avez-vous
appris à lancer la troisième base comme ça
j'étais fasciné de demander  questions
nées pour faire des interviews
bien je suis né pour être ce que
je fais  dans la rue à new york
et un ami me présente james
sermons
qui était chef de cabinet des annonceurs à cbs
homme merveilleux et je lui ai dit je
veux entrer dans la radio que dois-je faire
et il a dit descendre à miami il n'y a pas de
syndicat
beaucoup de stations beaucoup de stations de radio
plus de stations que le marché n'en a besoin
et donc vous trouverez des gars plus âgés
et des gars plus jeunes très peu de 40 ans
pour être une bonne chance d'entrer par effraction et j'ai
frappé aux portes d'une petite
station wahr in  Miami  la plage
m'a donné un travail et j'étais disc-jockey
et le 1er mai 1957
j'ai commencé à l'antenne et à partir de ce
moment
où cette lumière s'est allumée et j'ai dit au
public que c'était mon premier jour
ne jamais mentir au public
je euh j'ai trouvé mon  magie
alors mes rêves de ce que c'était toujours
maintenant j'avais des directeurs de programme je n'aimais pas
j'avais la gestion peut-être mais je n'ai
jamais jamais et cette lumière s'est allumée
n'a pas aimé ce que je faisais garçon
tu es naturel ouais
je pense que je pense  les bons diffuseurs
sont naturels et j'ai eu la chance
d'être
entouré de gens comme arthur godfrey et jackie gleason wow
euh godfrey j'ai co-animé une émission avec lui
pendant une semaine gleason m'a
tellement appris et jackie m'a dit
le seul secret dans cette affaire
est qu'il n'y a pas de secret sois toi
-même si tu es toi-même hé
c'est ce que c'était
je me souviens que j'étais interviewé au canada de tous les
endroits et ce gars m'a dit bien en
supposant que tu marchais dans le couloir
à nbc
quelqu'un t'a attrapé asseyez-vous dit
tom brokaw est malade
tu es sur  que feriez-vous
je dirais que je marchais dans le couloir
ce gars vient de m'attraper et a dit que tom
nous a rendu malade et je vais
bien maintenant je vais faire de mon mieux la
transparence je n'ai pas ancré les nouvelles
mais  vous dites au public que, alors vous faites
gaffe, hé,
ils les ont juste attrapés pour faire ça, comment
pouvez-vous vous tromper
si vous leur dites ce qui se passe, partagez
le processus
correct, je vous aime pour cela, vous avez
absolument raison,
alors vous êtes à Miami 50 dollars par  jour
tout nouveau gamin de brooklyn est soudainement
le gamin du sud de la floride
vous obtenez votre toute première interview avec une
célébrité
parce que vous faites votre émission depuis
le restaurant pumpernick à miami beach
et un gars entre qui chante
quelque part de l'
autre côté de la mer et son nom était
bobby darren oh le choc qu'ils ont
touché les dents du cerf et il le garde
purement blanc bobby est entré
il n'a pas dormi il travaillait au
pigeonnier de l'autre côté de la rue
et donc il a commencé à m'écouter
et il voulait voir ce que c'était  était
tout ce que je fais  le petit-déjeuner avec
pumpernickson
bobby était un invité formidable et après le
spectacle, nous avons descendu l'avenue collins
et je lui ai dit où va toute cette
énergie, il était tellement
hyper où ça va, il dit bien
je ne vais pas vivre passé  40.
il avait le rachitisme quand il était enfant une maladie cardiaque
alors il savait qu'il n'allait pas
avoir une longue vie
et il a dit je veux tout maintenant
vous ne l'avez jamais vu dans une boîte de nuit avez-vous
whoa
quel artiste lui et sammy  davis
bobby down courrait jouer de la batterie
jeter les baguettes en l'air l'
attraper derrière son dos
jouer avec le public et c'était un
gars formidable je me sentais si triste quand il est
décédé
mais il était le premier la
chose intéressante est la veille de votre départ
interviewer une serveuse à pumpernicks
et ensuite vous interviewez
bobby daron et cela montre simplement
que je suppose que
ce que larry nous a décrit lorsque vous
interviewez quelqu'un, que ce soit un artiste hip-hop
ou le président des états-unis, est-
ce la même interview
dans un  sens c'est qui quoi où quand pourquoi
qui quoi où quand pourquoi est l'essence
de toutes les interviews
et j'essaie d'entrer beaucoup dans le sage
pourquoi voulez-vous faire cela qu'est-ce que vous en
retirez et ma curiosité
quelqu'un m'a demandé si  tu as interviewé
Oussama ben Laden
que lui poserais-tu bien
la première question la plus stupide serait à
mon avis
pourquoi as-tu bombardé tous ces gens
parce qu'alors tu les mets sur la défensive
non tu veux qu'est-ce que je veux quand
j'interviewe Oussama  des
informations sur ben laden que je veux savoir sur lui,
donc ma question serait que vous avez été acheté
dans l'une des familles les plus riches d'
arabie saoudite pourquoi êtes-vous parti
pourquoi êtes-vous allé vivre dans des grottes
maintenant je vais en venir à sa motivation
et  j'ai appris cela il y a longtemps
personne ne pense qu'ils sont mauvais
hitler ne s'est pas levé le matin venir
ses cheveux et dire que je suis une personne terrible et maléfique
osama ben laden avait un but maintenant
où il se manifeste nous allons
apprendre  au
fur et à mesure de l'interview, comment il est arrivé là
où il était  c'est ce qu'il a ressenti à l'idée de faire
ça,
mais je vais le découvrir,
puis l'événement d'
abord lui, puis l'événement
si je vais d'abord à l'événement et que j'ai du
mal à en apprendre davantage sur lui,
donc je suis curieux de connaître les gens
le  la personne l'événement vient plus tard
donc c'est la même chose que ce soit un
président
ou bobby darren ou rick sanchez
ou un caméraman
et des étalons turkle m'a dit une fois le grand
chicago
tout le monde est intéressant
tout le monde est intéressant oui bonnes
questions
tu apprendras beaucoup je me souviens que tu l'as
dit  m'a demandé une fois que personne ne puisse
interviewer sinatra interviewer l'
opérateur d'ascenseur
il est intéressant aussi
vous racontez une belle histoire quand vous
avez commencé dans l'entreprise où,
comme nous tous, vous avez fait une
erreur importante vous vous êtes éloigné du studio
pour faire quelque chose et  je pense qu'est-ce que
tu as laissé euh tu as laissé une chanson en train de jouer et
elle a sauté
non non non ça n'a pas sauté
jockey et sports et nouvelles et vous savez que
vous avez travaillé
avec vous étiez à l'antenne 10 heures par jour
et euh un jour, le directeur général de la
station a dit que le gars de toute la nuit
est malade, feriez-vous l'émission toute la nuit,
bien sûr que je vais  faites n'importe quoi donc tout ce que vous faites est de
jouer des disques et de parler
et l'ingénieur ils n'avaient pas de
moteur toute la nuit c'était une petite station
quelques conversations en clair à trois
heures du matin
je réponds au téléphone wahr et cette voix la voix de
cette femme  dit que
je te veux et euh
j'ai soudainement réalisé qu'il y avait d'autres
avantages
dans cette entreprise alors j'ai dit que
je descendais à six heures et elle a dit que je devais
aller travailler à 6 heures.
pourquoi ne viens-tu pas maintenant je m'assieds
pendant que je '  je suis à l'antenne,
elle dit bien j'habite à neuf pâtés de maisons
voici mon adresse
trouve quelque chose parce que je suis très
attiré par toi
et j'ai eu mon premier dilemme
dilemme moral je veux être à la radio toute
ma vie
et c'est la première femme qui  m'a
jamais dit dans ma vie
que je te veux alors euh
ce que le public a entendu c'est que j'ai comme
une gâterie spéciale pour toi ce soir
tu vas entendre
tout l'album de
harry belafonte carnegie hall
sans interruption
j'ai eu 33 minutes ce qui est tout le temps dont j'avais
besoin
ouais ce qui est toujours vrai à ce jour alors
euh
j'ai mis le disque sur est allé à  sa maison
la lumière était allumée juste au-dessus de la porte
je suis entré je ne l'ai jamais vraiment vue
clairement elle était en déshabillé blanc
assise sur le canapé la radio était sur
le chant de harry
j'ai mis mes bras autour et ma joue est
contre sa joue droite
et harry  chantant adieu à la Jamaïque et
il arrive en
bas du chemin où les nuits où les
nuits
où les nuits oh aucun disque reste bloqué
je la remets sur le canapé je monte dans
la voiture
j'allume la radio ça s'appelle le masochisme juif
je rentre en voiture  à l'
audience de la station de radio où les nuits où les
nuits où la nuit
et vous savez que je pensais que je perdrais mon travail
mais je ne l'ai pas fait
mais je réponds au téléphone en m'excusant
auprès des gens
et le dernier appel que je décroche est comme un
homme juif plus âgé et  j'ai dit qu'il passait de
meilleures nuits de meilleures nuits tu
me rends fou avec de meilleures nuits
j'ai dit pourquoi tu ne changerais pas de
station
et il a dit que je suis invalide oh non une infirmière
prend soin de moi pendant  la journée et la
radio est en haut de la commode
je ne peux pas l'atteindre donc je garde votre station
allumée toute la
journée c'était l'une de mes premières aventures mais
heureusement je n'ai pas perdu mon emploi
j'ai été dans les médias un  longtemps rt
est l'une des rares chaînes à faire des nouvelles rt
fait des
nouvelles c'est mon pays le plus grand spectacle sur
terre
dis la vérité
[Musique]
tu portais des bretelles en mon honneur je n'ai jamais
oublié que
je n'ai jamais oublié d'où je
venais  moi
c'est l'un des grands honneurs de ma
longue carrière juste d'être
sur la même terre que
toi tu as fait quelque chose d'intéressant larry tu as
été le premier à faire
une émission nationale à la radio
avec je crois que c'était le réseau mutuel
ça s'appelait  larry king
uh live je crois et le larry king
montre que c'était un
mu  réseau tual c'était l'idée d'ed little
qu'il dirigeait le réseau et j'ai dit
dans le premier talk-show national de nashville
comment le talk-show national allait
fonctionner
je veux dire comment ça va être intéressant
si j'ai le maire de chicago sur
pourquoi quelqu'un dans  la et il a dit
parce que tu es le genre de
personne parfait pour faire ça parce que tu es curieux
de tout
et de ce que cette émission a fait je serais assis là
la nuit rick
avait 20 lignes entrantes ils sonnent tous
je ferais attention à  ma gauche et regarde c'était
diffusé depuis la virginie
mais je verrais toute la ville de washington de
minuit à cinq et j'ai eu un bal
j'ai eu de supers invités bill clinton a
appelé un soir quand il était gouverneur
à trois heures du matin et j'ai dit quoi
Est-ce que tu te lèves à trois heures du matin,
a-t-il dit, tant
pis, Cosby a couru de Washington dans les
rues pour venir à l'émission de radio.
montrer
où après vous êtes arrivé où y  ous
deviez l'être si vous conduisiez dans votre voiture pendant 45
minutes vous vous asseyiez dans votre voiture
sur le parking parce que vous vouliez
entendre le reste de la conversation ce qui
allait se passer ensuite les
gens appellent certaines des personnes les plus
drôles de  le monde appellerait
parce que ce serait un téléphone ouvert en Amérique
après le départ d'un invité,
tout pourrait arriver un gars pourrait appeler à
propos de la
république dominicaine le prochain gars a appelé à propos
des red sox
et j'étais tellement dans tout cela
que c'était probablement je veux dire cnn  était
génial et
j'adore ce que je fais maintenant
mais c'était probablement le plus amusant que
j'aie jamais eu mais il me semble corrigez-moi
si je me trompe
vous n'avez jamais vraiment arrêté de faire de la radio
quand vous êtes allé à la
télé beaucoup de gens je  Je ne veux pas dire
vendre, mais
je suis soudainement tombé amoureux de la caméra et du look et tout ce que vous n'arrêtez jamais de faire, vous l'avez compris,
je vais vous dire quelque chose que je considère la
télévision en
ce moment, ce que nous faisons, c'est la radio avec
un  caméra
ok c'est tout ce que les gens peuvent s  nous voir
mais vous pouvez
éteindre la caméra et nous écouter
alors
je me suis dit que beaucoup de gars de la radio n'ont pas
bien réussi à la télévision
parce qu'ils ont réagi comme vous savez que
j'ai réagi à  c'est comme hé
caméra trouve-moi je suis je suis avec rick et je
pose des questions à rick
et c'est la radio avec des images c'est tout c'est
chaque émission que j'ai jamais faite tu peux juste
écouter
c'était ta décision parce que quand tu es
allé  sur cnn je n'y ai jamais pensé comme
une décision
ted turner m'aimait bien il avait été invité à mon
émission de radio
il avait vu mon travail à la télévision locale j'ai
toujours fait de la télévision à la
télévision à miami
et donc quand il m'a mis sur
cnn  pense que larry king
live et mario cuomo était le premier invité
et
je me souviens que la nuit du 1er juin
1985 c'était le cinquième anniversaire de cnn
et je continue et c'est comme un
problème rigoureux
suppose que le gouverneur cuomo nous étions dans les
petits studios de
georgetown mais je savais que  la nuit qui marcherait
je savais juste que ça marcherait  rk et ted turner
se sont avérés être le
meilleur gars qui ait jamais travaillé pour personne comme lui
et ii la chance aussi d'ailleurs paul
newman m'a dit quelque chose une fois c'est tellement
vrai
toute personne qui réussit dans
n'importe quel domaine qui, en discutant de sa vie
ne le fait pas  utilisez le mot la chance est un menteur
je me fiche de qui vous êtes la chance a joué un
rôle
tourner à gauche tourner à droite et si je ne
courais pas aux sermons de james ce jour-là
maintenant quelqu'un dirait bien vous
auriez réussi la
chance est le résidu  de la branche de conception
rickey a dit que
pas si sûr que bébé ruth a dit que je préférerais avoir de la
chance que du
bien ouais une des grandes citations
de tous les temps si vous avez de la chance
vous l'avez eu fait que la chance vous tombe dessus
vous ne savez pas ce que c'est mais  quand vous
frappez la balle ce gars fait l'erreur
et ensuite vous profitez du
verrouillage d'erreur
donc cnn se porte très bien et la star
de cnn
pour ne pas vous embarrasser était larry king vous
aviez les notes les plus élevées vous étiez le
meilleur spectacle
donc il y a un  upstart ça s'appelle fox
news et ils ont ce gars qui s'appelle bill
o'reilly
et bill o'reilly arrive et il pense
qu'il va être une sorte d'
intimidateur
et il va devenir célèbre en s'en
prenant au grand gars de cnn
alors nuit et nuit il commence à
te frapper dans le nez sur  l'air
et dire que tu n'es pas bon et que tu es
ennuyeux et ceci et cela
et puis je pense qu'il y a enfin un
moment un jour Larry alors que je me souviens
où il arrive enfin à te confronter
et tu lui as dit quelque chose d'
intéressant parce qu'il disait  il
critiquait la façon dont tu fais la télé
et tu as dit quelque chose comme tu le fais à
ta façon
et je le ferai à ma façon et ça vient de terminer
le moment
et c'était si sincère et
alors fais-moi traverser cet homme il y a de la place
pour tout
le monde dans le  affaires vous trouvez votre schtick
et il
était un tyran de diffusion et cela a fonctionné
et foxwork pour l'appeler fox news est un
oxymoron
ce n'est pas des nouvelles et non vous faites la
dernière émission de nouvelles
à la télévision il n'y a pas de nouvelles cnn
ne fait pas de
nouvelles c'est  Trump tout le temps,
c'est Trump TV et
CNN a aidé  faites de l'atout en le couvrant à
partir de la minute où il a annoncé qu'ils
couvraient
ses discours quand il y avait 20 gars qui
couraient
ils couvraient l'atout ils couvraient l'atout
nous avions une chose appelée
temps égal dans notre entreprise où nos
directeurs de l'information nous disaient
non vous ne pouvez pas  interviewez ce gars parce
qu'ensuite nous avons dû amener l'autre gars
ce qui s'est passé doctrine d'équité ouais nous
devions être justes
ce qui n'allait pas avec ça vous ne pouviez pas
entendre les nouvelles ne pouvaient pas exister en
vertu de cette loi vous deviez donner un temps égal à
chaque fois qu'ils  j'ai fait quelque chose
donc je suis un peu triste à propos de l'entreprise
aujourd'hui je n'aime pas beaucoup de ce que je vois
donc je compte sur le sport que
je regarde je pense que c'est une chaîne sous-estimée
ils font vraiment beaucoup de bonnes choses ils
ont si mal  un terme impropre comme la russie les
contrôle c'est des bêtises
je n'ai jamais eu d'
invité qu'ils n'ont pas couru j'ai été
critiqué par putin
trois fois par semaine ils n'ont jamais
fermé ça ce sont des gens vraiment sympas
pour travailler
ils ne méritent pas  l'image qu'ils ont
eue  t qu'il y a une sorte d'entité étrangère
je ne pense pas qu'ils soient étrangers je ne
pense pas qu'ils soient étrangers
Je travaille pour les britanniques ou les russes
ou les français ou les
américains ouais je t'ai dit de prendre le travail
merci oui tu l'as fait tu étais la première
personne que j'ai appelée
ton conseil était super il y a une
interview que je regardais
qui était vraiment intéressante parce que
c'est  une des rares fois
et ensuite nous parlerons de quelques autres je
ne sais pas nous interviewons cette femme
qui était miss californie son nom était
carrie prejean
oh ouais et c'est l'une des rares fois où
je t'ai jamais vu  être un peu
énervée parce
qu'elle s'est fâchée contre moi parce que je lui ai demandé
qu'elle courait et qu'elle ne voulait pas
répondre à une question quand elle courait
pour miss californie
et elle a dit que c'était inapproprié elle a
enlevé le micro
et je suis juste allé  avec ça tu sais que je viens
je n'étais pas vraiment énervé tu sais à la
télévision
c'est la seule fois à la télévision peu
importe ce qui se passe
les producteurs disent continuez continuez continuez comme
ça ouais hé l'endroit brûle
gardez le feu se
rapprocher du feu qu'elle prend  son
micro éteint et vous lui dites que
vous pouvez être en colère et que vous pouvez dire tout
ce que vous avez besoin de dire mais assurez-vous d'avoir
votre micro allumé
oh il y a beaucoup d'entre vous savez
des moments drôles c'est une affaire amusante mais
la chose que j'ai aimée à ce sujet  et la chose qui
me manque le plus,
c'est en direct j'ai fait de la radio en direct toute ma vie
j'ai fait de la télévision en direct maintenant je ne fais pas de
direct tu sais
sur rt et aura
c'est enregistré et tu sais que la bande est toujours
professionnelle je la traite comme un
professionnel
mais  vivre rien ne vaut vivant
c'est ce moment
hé tu as été marié huit fois
sept fois
sept fois ouais
mais le dernier a 22 ans
est là je ne me souviens pas de ne pas être
je fais tu tombes amoureux
ouais j'ai eu un  théorie
que ce que j'aimais quand j'avais 20 ans.
Ce n'était pas ce que j'aimais quand j'avais 30
ans.
65 ans
65 ans combien de compromis avez
-vous fait
au cours de ces 65 années et
mon problème majeur était
mon euh cnn est venu devant la femme
iod est venu devant la femme alors
j'avais l'habitude de dire si j'avais deux messages
appeler la maison appeler cnn appeler  cnn d'abord
cela a changé dans ce mariage
vous traversez beaucoup de hauts et de bas
je ne suis pas sûr que l'institution
soit géniale en d'autres termes
pourquoi l'État est-il impliqué
dans un mariage pourquoi pourquoi avez-vous besoin d'une
licence d'État
pourquoi d'accord je comprends les
enfants et  les juges doivent s'occuper des
enfants
pourquoi pourquoi c'est
d'abord la monogamie allez
tu me dis c'est facile la monogamie
hey euh le mot retraite existe t'il même
dans ton vocabulaire
comme j'ai demandé à milton berle une fois que tu
vas prendre ta retraite et il a dit à quoi
que ferais-je alors j'ai 85 ans j'ai vécu une
longue
vie j'ai battu tant de santé je  ssues
j'ai subi un pontage cardiaque pour une crise cardiaque
une
chirurgie pulmonaire pour le cancer de la prostate
j'ai récemment reçu un diagnostic de
leucémie, mais c'était chronique et
non aigu, donc je prends une pilule tous les jours
et je dois me surveiller j'ai parfois un
peu d'essoufflement
tu te connais  ne rajeunis pas
mais j'aime toujours
le jour ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui
et quand tu es curieux et au fait
la clé du succès pour moi est la
curiosité
tu perds la curiosité il n'y a aucune raison mais
je suis tellement curieux de savoir
ce qui est  qui va gagner aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui
va se passer demain
qu'est-ce que c'est que tout ce que c'est que le
brexit voici ce que j'aimerais que ma nécrologie lise l'
homme le plus âgé de l'histoire du monde
est décédé aujourd'hui
abattu
par un mari jaloux
a mis trois semaines à  efface le sourire de
son visage
je sais que je vais y aller mais je ne veux pas
y aller mais je pense que
je suis fier de ce que j'ai fait
je suis dans les médias depuis longtemps rt est l'
un des rares  chaînes faisant des nouvelles
rt fait des nouvelles c'est la
plus grande émission de mon pays sur  terre dis la vérité
toi